thank you
[Music]
in the realm of funny jokes that are not
very good there is a finish man uh who
reportedly stored 12 kilos or 26.5
pounds of dynamite in two cars belonging
to a friend saying that it was a joke no
I will it's just a joke
do you have the wire you kind of love it
just like the TNT dynamite he's wearing
a coyote outfit Mr Beast video
he's just wearing an Acme suit not sure
dude that's a good prank is always real
it was real dynamite it was real
dynamite how you get how you get in a
friend's car
but is it like dynamite where like he
can't he like works with dynamite so
it's not as like crazy to him you know
like when construction guys do pranks
they do [__] that we're like could never
think of doing that
uh it doesn't say that he works with
dynamite it doesn't it actually says it
was not known where the explosives came
from [__] that's even crazier lean wants
to see a picture of the dynamite yeah I
sure do and I would say pictures does it
say TNT on the dynamite TNT
it does not does it just like dynamite
yeah you have you guys seen real
dynamite no what does it look like yeah
I only see cartoon Dynamite I really
have not really seen it I definitely
know what cartoon Dynamite looks like a
little red six yeah yeah and then the
really long it's outdated
yeah it has to have changed over the
years
as far as the cartoon visual goes what
is C4 really is it Dynamite yeah it
looks exactly the same that's exactly it
looks explosive isn't it oh BTS Dynamite
oh good I want to see can you get some
from Amazon very cool
is it rolled like a roll of quarters it
comes like firecracker what it looks
like that's right oh wow so I guess so
it's accurate yeah all right all right
it's a modern everything
that looks like movie times
that's exactly what Dynamite looks like
dude that looks like a product photo
that looks like the Universal Studios
Western show yeah
dude all right check this out when you
Google Dynamite
yeah real dynamite type in real uncut
yeah yeah uncensored
dynamite dynamite nude type in homemade
Dynamite amateur Dynamite how to make
homemade
Simon but like you could look up how to
make a bomb can't you like it's frowned
upon but yeah like look at all these
images if it's not red it says Dynamite
on it you're right dude
hey what if that's a law what if that's
a law that even like bombers follow
where like if you make a bomb it has to
look like a bomb so you can find it yeah
who was the first person did you know
like when they defuse it the wiring is
always like the they can figure it out
right yeah rather than just like all
white wires
the blue nope green
oh [__] dude we like throwing um m80s
down toilets that was pretty crazy right
yeah that blows the whole toilet up it's
crazy so it's like mini Dynamite yeah
you know
it's going too far Dynamite for a prank
well it depends on what kind of jokes
they make you probably don't watch
in a car nah I'm not gonna start this
movie he likes two cars here here's an
example watch don't don't react vocally
look in that red thing you see that red
thing yeah don't don't make any sound
just look in it you like these kind of
pranks
yeah vocally Nick
how did you do that
are those the kind you like are you like
dynamite based ones better this is the
worst
show clean just look at it
what's what's that what's that all right
Joe you look at it
just don't say anything just look at it
that's supposed to be JK memories just
don't say anything supposed to be JK
memories
did you print that out just for that is
there more yeah you did
is there more is that why you were short
pictures
you gotta go through more yeah you gotta
I'm kind of horrified through it
do you do you wish that it was a
dynamite one or not that is dynamite
this I'd honestly rather dude
it's crazy
no no don't never know only people are
signed up for patreon will know what's
in there sometimes when I'm walking in
my car I think Ryan has something set up
for me like I'm afraid he's gonna pop
out and scare me and you actually did I
mean it's just a mental issue no you did
that to me one time remember you said
you sucked your car right now
Ryan's like a magician he's like David
Blaine he's like go ahead and go to your
car now yeah
just cough up a frog holy [__] right
it's like I appreciate this it's pretty
cool I I'm honestly so who called the
cops who got who got uh the owner of the
two cars didn't see it as funny and they
informed the police who briefly detained
the potential prankster
so no charges
uh the suspect faces up to two years in
prison I'm curious to see what their
relationship and if this guy's just a
[__] ass dude you know like if the guy
who called the cops is a total [__] ass
for having dynamite in his car not
knowing where it came from but it's his
buddy right well
he probably just found dynamite in his
car well he's probably not good at
knowing his friends that's illegal
though that's not a nice prank if it's
illegal where like death is a
possibility or yeah or just being
arrested for having something you're not
supposed to and you're going I don't
know how that got there and the cop's
like sure Bud
picture yeah that's not nice how do you
know that it was his friend
did he knows his friend
um maybe I don't know it didn't say
he's but it says that the suspect
admitted to placing the explosives there
in the cause but said he didn't intend
to blow them up what if he was trying to
kill attention I think he was trying to
kill him oh yeah that's true because
then you could just say it was a prank
even though your intention they also
live in a small village in the western
part of Finland so it was probably one
of those like how the heck do you get
died in my place like that they got a
[__] up sense of humor over there
is that a stereotype yeah
stereotypically Finnish people love
pranking each other with dynamite they
have dark humor and they love explosives
that's the thing dark humor is a Finnish
thing
I also made up of Grease of this again
yeah this you want to see the there's a
change yeah this is probably where you
guys keep riffing while I look at the
only Finnish people I know are the
Dudesons
so Joe just did this a hundred times
it's two pictures
there's five pictures it gets stuck you
got weak ass fingers bro
wow this one's a good one you could also
just pull it out and look at it
wow yeah just pulled it out you know you
could get that made I don't know the guy
at the store [__] laugh you're a fan
when did you do this I just you just do
it online oh really yeah where's the JK
one you have it hit it right there okay
all right you are a [__] genius
this guy I was hoping I put it right
there because I thought one day you'd
just be fiddling around and then you'd
just be like [__] around talking and
then you just look but it felt that was
creepier honestly feel better to just
like tell you in the middle of a prank
video Everybody yeah
they're all photos of Nick also that
middle photo what was that from one
thing I was just sitting across from you
taking photos of you and then I uploaded
it to this website and it mailed me this
[Applause]
whatever his name is the fighter I
should know his [__] name
that you can custom these yeah
like growing up Ryan for sure was oh
dude I lived for that [__] what was like
one of the most [__] up pranks you've
done for like the scariest thing or a
prank that you you could have got in
trouble for that's like adjacent I could
have got in trouble for like you know
what in high school uh towards the end
of the year they had this thing where
like 8th graders visit the high school
to like check it out and see if they
want to go to school there so they'll
plan all these activities for them and
they do these games we have like a rock
climbing wall where like all the kids
would like you know uh try to climb the
wall had nothing to do I don't know if
it was effective but then like uh the
top of the wall ends where the roof of
the school like starts oh [__] so then I
filled up this giant Basin of water and
then I went up to the roof and then as
the kids were climbing I dumped all this
water down they all fell
is it really high up it's two stories
how I went there but they're on the
they're on the Rope yeah yeah I saw it
was funny because they weren't expecting
it and they're covered in water I was a
senior by that point so that's my little
mo was just to prank people two kids
died
instead of getting in trouble this is
such a [__] like stupid thing so I
did that and in instead of like a
teacher getting mad at me or something
it caused like a water fight to start
and the whole like school just started
everyone was just throwing water on each
other it started like a school water
fight that's done and by the time I got
back down the stairs I ran into my
teacher Mr Snyder who's like the science
teacher I thought he was gonna yell at
me but he splashed me with water and ran
that's so cool it was a real [__]
Legend it was like it was so cool
like multiple Seasons That's a series
but honestly that's you know sanity I'm
in the school it's like if it's as long
you're not hurting anybody it's kind of
funny really but two kids died the two
kids died
yeah all my pranks are wholesome
yeah
they're not like I don't like to hurt no
of course I thought you're gonna rub dog
[__] all over the Rocks that's my
elementary pranks jokes
he gets a Basketball picks up tonight no
I would do that I would do that at like
fourth grade I would go out in the
because you know like he's evolved that
starts everyone races for the basketball
to like you know play I would it would
just be smeared and [__] and then
everyone's just grabbing it and they all
started passing it to like start they're
like what the [__]
it breaks down
basketball
wait did anybody like in in your history
of pranks did anybody do a prank on you
that you're like damn that was good yeah
but really low brow pranks like like one
of the worst things is one time I was it
was like in sixth grade you know you
have to line up before you like get go
into the classroom so we had to line up
and I'm like looking this girl I liked I
was like looking at her far away trying
to like get her to like just go do
stupid faces to try to get her look at
me and my friend pants to me at the same
time is that a prank or is that just
started laughing yeah it was showing no
it's too small
that's that's the kind of [__] people
would pull on me it's like they would
pull unelaborate but there was never
like a prank that inspired meanwhile
Ryan's sitting at home with the
forethought to be like I'm going to take
it
that's such a long con dude like anyone
has patience it's a long game yeah Ryan
is the most awesome agreed agreed
no because they're too clever yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's always propped you can't
be mad at it you know it is very clever
but there's some shitty people that are
dumb that don't take that I think I
would have pulled pranks on people that
I think would be mad at me yeah
Nick needs more pranks you prank me a
lot dude this guy remember the electric
rods one that's [__] dude that's
crazy so [__] up he's trying to booby
trap me there was consensual came into
that no this is what happened you agreed
on camera no that that's not the problem
I have the problem I have is no no no no
this is what I do with my dogs too no no
no no no this [__] put the rods
in my backpack on the handle so as I go
to reach for it I would [__] get
shocked but I [__] saw it maybe I
[__] saw coming and he didn't get me
but I did touch it afterwards yeah I
also fill his backpack with all the
snacks
I came home I had my backpack and I had
a bunch of [__] snacks in there and
then I was like here I was like what the
[__] is in my bag I look in filled with
snacks oh I see Bart one time he just
finished eating he saw like all the
forks and stuff he just went
yeah doing it too I had a bunch of forks
in my [__] and I was like Ryan what the
[__] why'd you put all these plastic
forks that's another classic prank that
uh it was created on tour basically like
if you get like a tortilla and then you
just try to place it on someone's
shoulder and then you get everybody
around the room to start making puns
about tortillas and they'll just be like
anything you guys want to talk about
today like you just say like taco like
whoever can hide the most tortilla based
puns in their sentence like wins until
that person
did that with cheese at a party one yeah
and that's what we call it the game's
called quesa the dealers yeah
Ryan's across from the room is like hey
looking real cheesy
you have to start off the first the rule
is you have to start off by saying
someone's got a case of the dealers and
then like then everybody knows like so
stupid yeah oh my God yeah and everybody
just go like this yeah they do but the
person usually you get is like new so it
has never played yeah one time we're
gonna drink with all the Jutsu guys and
my coach kept putting um
like I never drink and they got me to
take a shot so I was like I was having
fun this is like the the night before
like the week before covet happened yeah
and these [__] and I was
wearing a hoodie and they kept putting
cheese rolls into my hoodie
and I there's a video of me somewhere
where I'm in the bathroom and I see the
hoodie and there's a mirror and I look
and I go what I'm peeing and I was like
what the [__] it was like five girls
that's really good you have to eat it to
be like [__] you you know but they they
were just hiding pornos cheese rolls in
my [__] head
okay
tired but they got me and I was like
this is the funniest [__] ever we did
the same thing with Sashimi one time
there was a bunch of Sashimi at a party
and then and then we put it on this
girl's shoulder like a little sashimi
and we kept asking her have you ever had
shoulder fish
and she kept going no what's that they
were like you've never had shoulder fish
like oh dude it's good have you had
salmon yeah it's like that but it's like
just a little different yeah it's just
on the show that was an article right
that was an article that was on way too
long on yeah
foreign